hey guys Craig Knuckles here with string
theory calm and what I have for you
today is a QA video about the Bulgarian
method as most of you probably know Omar
Issa and I recently released a free
Bulgarian training manual link will be
in the description and thus far it's
already been downloaded over 16,000
times so a lot of questions have rolled
in and the purpose of this video is to
answer as many of them as possible
especially the ones that have come up
frequently so the first question that's
come up a lot has to do with deadlifts
the Bulgarian method for powerlifting as
we lay it out in the manual primarily
revolves around squatting and pressing
and people who like the deadlift you
know they're a little bit peeved to that
hey we only recommend pulling once or
twice a week submaximal not really the
type of brutal deadlift workouts that
they're used to so they're asking is
there any way that we can pull more
frequently or work harder deadlift
workouts into the overall plan and yes
you can if you want to pull more
frequently what I would recommend is
doing them clean pull style kind of like
a weightlifter deadlifts tend to be more
fatiguing if you're really pulling max
weights or pulling sets close to failure
where your backgrounds a little bit and
that rounding of your back your spine
going through flexion and extension
instead of just being held isometrically
that tends to be more fatiguing on your
back then even pulling a lot of reps
with really really clean form so I would
recommend if you want to pull more
frequently stay a long way away from
failure with pretty manageable weights
and like I said pull kind of like an
Olympic style clean pull where there's
no flexion all up and down the spine
even in the thoracic region which tends
to be more acceptable for powerlifting
style deadlifts if you do want to work
harder deadlift workouts into the
overall setup of the Bulgarian method
the way
we lay it out just be aware that you're
better squats will probably be affected
for at least two or three days
afterwards so you'll want to be more
conservative with your daily minimum
because your daily well what you're
capable of doing the day or two after a
heart deadlift workout will be knocked
down considerably so you'll want to be
more conservative with your daily
minimum and also just be aware that your
daily maxes will probably be affected
for a couple days after a heart deadlift
workout and it may be wise just hit the
daily minimum and wrap it up for that
day or two after so what you're dealing
with there is kind of a trade-off you
can work the heavier deadlifts in if you
want to but that will decrease how often
you can train your squat really hard so
if that's a trade-off you're fine with
that's okay and if not just just keep
that in the back of your mind and train
the deadlift more conservatively the way
it's recommended in the manual okay
second question that's come up a lot has
to do with calculating training volume
and its importance in the overall setup
so one of the things I talked about in
the manual is training volume on the
bulgarians method just like every other
style of training is still the main
driver of progress so if you're stalling
the main the main way to keep moving
forward is to increase your training
volume so the questions have been like
how how rigorously do I need to
calculate that is that something that I
need to increase rigidly in regular
intervals or something like that and the
answer to that is no and really the
training volume of any given day isn't
overly important because you're training
the lifts so frequently however it's
probably a good idea to keep a rolling
average of how many drop back sets
you're doing for each lift each week and
just have that in the back of your mind
and if you're still making progress
basically just allow that to auto
regulate and you'll be fine if you find
that you've been stalled for two three
four weeks and you look back and how
many drop backs since you're doing and
it's been pretty much flatlined then it
would probably be a good idea
to push those a little bit harder and
maybe do one or two extra drop back sets
per workout that you wouldn't typically
do just to make sure you're getting some
extra volume in to keep that Weekly
rolling average moving up and then as
you establish that higher level of
volume you'll keep you'll start making
progress again and you know just hold
there until you plateau again and then
increase volume and you know rinse and
repeat so the next question a lot of
people have been asking has to do with
accessory lifts the Bulgarian method for
powerlifting as we've laid it out
primarily just revolves around squatting
and pressing and so people are asking
well that obviously leads a lot of
muscles untrained so what do we do about
those um so really just a general rule
of thumb is you can do whatever you want
to for those muscles as long as it
doesn't take away from the quality of
work that you can do for your main lifts
so you know let's say you want to do
some extra back work you want to work
your lats a little bit harder if you can
do you know let's say two or three sets
of rows or pull-ups and you come in the
next day your lats aren't sore you can
still squat and bench fine then that's
fine and that's a perfectly acceptable
thing to do if you do that same amount
of volume and your lats are really sore
and you find it harder to keep your
torso stable and solid when you're
squatting or your shoulders feel a
little bit loose when you're benching
then that was probably a little bit too
much and just like the squatting and
benching any any level of work that
you're doing for those other muscles
start conservatively and increase over
time as you're able and it's always best
to err on the side of too little rather
than too much when you're first starting
out and then as you kind of see what
your body's comfort zone is with those
lifts just increase those over time as
you're able okay another question that's
come in quite a bit is would you
recommend a Bulgarian style training
when training for insert sport here it
could be anything some people have asked
about running some people have asked
about football or wrestling things like
that I would say no and the reason for
that is I wouldn't
recommend any type of powerlifting
program while you're training
specifically for another sport as your
primary focus and the reason for that is
any good program that focuses on a
particular physical attribute in this
case powerlifting and strength or I mean
it could be anything a good running
program for example what what that
specialty program is doing basically is
pushing your recovery ability basically
to the limit if you can do more and
you're not doing more then you're not
getting as much as you can out of the
program so by their very nature most
powerlifting programs this included are
having you do powerlifting things
basically to the edge of your recovery
any good running program will be having
you running basically to the edge of
your recovery because if you could do
more and you're not then the programs
not as effective as it could be so if
you're training for say two sports at
the same time or if you're you know if
you want to do something like the
Bulgarian method plus you know train for
running or train for another sport
that's probably not a particularly good
thing to do because if you're doing a
specialty program like the Bulgarian
method that focuses primarily on
strength and that's pushing you to the
very edge of your recovery ability as it
should be
then when you add on the extra stress of
the other sport or the extra stress of
running or anything like that that's
going to tip you over the edge of what
you'll be able to recover from and if it
doesn't that's a good indicator that you
aren't pushing as hard on the program as
you should have been in the first place
so my recommendation would be to seek
out a program that is tailored
specifically to say increasing strength
in the context of the practice of the
broader sport that you're trying to
improve at and just to give credit where
credit's due I think this is kind of a
concept that a lot of people have had in
the back of their minds but I've heard
it most clearly articulated by Alex
viata of complete human performance so
just to give credit where it's due
that's
that's who really helped distill that
idea for me another question that's come
up a lot has to do more generally with
training frequency and is it necessary
to Train lifts this often if you want to
get stronger and unequivocally my answer
is no if you look back through time most
grave lifters have trained their squat
bench deadlift once or twice a week
sometimes three times but there have
been plenty of people who got brutally
strong without this type of training
frequency all we were really trying to
do here is lay out you know if you're
interested in the style of training
here's how you can implement it it can
help you get strong other things can
help you get strong not certainly not
saying that Bulgarian style train is the
way you have to train if you want to get
stronger just simply that if it's a
style of training that interests you the
manual will no teach you how to
implement it intelligently if that is
the style of training that appeals to
you but again making no claim but it's
how you have to train if you want to get
stronger another question that's come up
pretty often is how infrequently can you
get away with training no because the
Bulgarian team they train seven days a
week two or three times a day most days
and obviously most of us don't have time
to do that so people are asking you know
can I do this if I'm training if I can
only get in the gym five days a week or
four days a week or you know what what
is that bottom end cut off and just
based on experience it seems to be about
four times a week five to six for most
people seems to be the sweet spot if you
can pull it off but people also make
great great progress with the style of
training four times a week in my
experience three times a week doesn't
tend to work quite as well and really
three times a week doesn't necessarily
qualify as high frequency training in
the first place not not saying it can't
work for you it's just that again just
based on what I've seen helping helping
people through the style of training and
talking to people who have done it and
asking for their experiences
it seems like about four times a week is
the bottom end cutoff for how frequently
you need to train those lifts to get the
most benefit from them another question
that's come up a lot has to do with the
overhead press the manual was primarily
written to power lifters and using
Bulgarian style training for
powerlifting so most of what we talked
about in the manual had pride was
primarily talking about the benchpress
when we discussed pressing however if
the overhead press is a higher priority
to you basically everything we say about
bench pressing you can just sub in
overhead pressing there and it all
applies a few people have also asked
about benching and overhead pressing and
how to Train both of those
simultaneously my recommendation would
be to pick the one you want to focus on
the most and do that for every training
day except maybe one or two and then do
the other lift just once or twice a week
you could split it up where you're
basically doing it 50/50
but again just based on my experience
with people who have worked through this
style of training that doesn't tend to
give enough frequency in the specific
motor patterns to have as bit of
carryover as training a lift at least
four times a week so you know if you can
get to the gym six times a week and
overhead presses your priority but you
also want to get your bench up then four
times a week overhead pressing and twice
a week benching or five and one that
tends to work fine intends to work
better than three and three what I've
seen happen most often is if you're you
know trying to serve two masters at the
same time you tend to get really good
overhead progress or really good bench
progress if you're focusing on that one
and then moderate progress on the other
one if you're only doing it once or
twice a week whereas if you're just
doing both of them you know two or three
times a week and not really focusing on
one or the other you tend to get that
moderate not so great progress for both
of them okay the last one this has
actually been asked about a dozen times
which
is on par with a lot of the other
questions even though I'm pretty sure
it's a joke question but I'll still give
it a serious answer people have asked
about what type of beer you should drink
when you're doing this type of training
and this can be very stressful training
and you know it requires adequate
calories to replenish so I would
recommend sticking primarily with
Imperial Scouts and quads Belgian
quadruples
as beer pairings for this type of
training you might be able to get away
with triples or maybe Imperial IPAs but
you know those those big hearty beers
tend to you know pack more calories and
help you recover from the style of
training better and people have also
asked what is the maximum amount of beer
I can drink which is a good question
because obviously with any type of
training program a very high priority is
being able to drink as much as possible
and still be able to make progress and
for that I would basically say obviously
never drink enough that you wind up with
a hangover and stick to two or three
standard drinks per day and if you're
going with those Imperial stouts and
quads since they have you know ten
percent ABV or above typically 12 ounces
of those you need to count as two
standard drinks because well it has
twice as much alcohol it's fake beer and
so in buy fake beer I mean most beer so
you know stick to two or three drinks a
day it's probably not going to affect
your recovery very much but it will very
much benefit your enjoyment of this type
of training for any type of training and
just life in general so that's it guys
thanks for watching like I said the
manuals free links in the description if
you have any more questions ask them in
the comments below please like and
subscribe that's all I got
thanks guys